what's that believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that awesomeness inside
you explode out into the world so you
can do something crazy special now to
help you on your journey today we're
going to talk about seven ways to plan
for the long term so one of the
questions I get asked often is how do I
plan how do I plan for my business not
just for the short term and immediate
sales but how do I plan for the longer
term how do you create a plan that's
gonna work that'll be realistic that'll
last me for a long time we have that
guiding point for me that I can also
sell to investors and the customers and
the partners and suppliers so today I'm
gonna share with you my seven tips on
how to plan for the long term we number
one is to have a mission you have to
have some big overarching goal that
never expires like you're here to have a
big impact change the world in some way
what does that look like and so it
should be something that you can't reach
in five years or ten years wherever but
it's an ideal that you're shooting
towards it's a reason why you are here
so for me I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs and it's not about
tracking it to actually know when I hit
a billion entrepreneurs it's a lifetime
goal it's never gonna be accomplished
but it's always an aspiration to go and
reach and so especially when you're
playing for the long term you need to
have that thing that's a driving force
behind what everybody is rallying for
because if you hit your big goal then
that's the purpose of your organization
and then you hit it then what are we
doing and this is confusion right and so
you want to have some big long term
mission here is a change that you want
to make on the world and you can start
attracting the team members to help you
go ahead and do it
[Music]
number two is people so you have this
big vision for what you want to do in
the world what are the people that you
will need to have on board your team to
be able to help you go and do it and it
starts with doing a self-assessment of
yourself what skills do you have what
can you be Michael Jordan at like what
do you have genius level talent ad that
you want to be one of the best in the
world at and then in order to accomplish
your big mission who are the people what
are the skills that you need to surround
yourself with and so you can have your
big vision of when I'm you know CEO or
maybe you're not even CEO maybe you're a
different position in the company need
to bring on a CEO but this is what you
want to do you know in the bigger term
the the bigger vision here's what you
want to do and to make that happen and
you just spend 90% of your time here you
need all of these people around you to
go off and do their thing so what do
those people look like what do the
skills look like and what is the order
who's the first hire who's the second
hire all the way up to what does that
big org structure look like number three
is in budget what does your budget look
like what's it gonna cost to get there
both from a perspective of in the next
year you know who's the person that you
need to hire how much is that going to
cost
and then that bigger term vision if you
want to hire 10 people 20 people a
hundred people how much money do you
need do you need to go ahead and raise
it can you do it from self financing
what are your expenses look like this is
gonna be really important for you for
your planning but also for investors
coming on board if you have a big dream
and you want investors to help fund it
they need to know what your mission is
you need to know who you need to bring
on and they need to know how much money
you need to make it all happen and how
much you're gonna make now a lot of this
is still assumptions its estimations
right it's looking at what's been done
and making an assumption of how much
things are going to cost so it won't be
perfect but having an idea of where
things are going will really help
because if you can't say here's how I'm
gonna spend this money you're giving me
nobody's gonna give you the money to
find your dream
[Music]
number four is understanding trends and
understanding do the trend support where
you're going or not you know if your
business is around self-driving cars
that's gonna happen it may not happen
right now may not happen in the next two
years but like five six ten years down
the road it's going to happen so that is
a trend that is really supporting you if
you need people to be driving in their
cars for your business to be a success
that's not a trend that's really
supporting you and so understanding
where trends are going and understanding
the realistic timeline for that
happening you want to focus on that and
have a clear understanding and put that
into your plan number five is
understanding technology is the
technology currently in place for you to
be able to do what you want to do or do
you need improvements in technology to
happen this is one of the things that
investors always look at in the business
plan if the technology is ready right
now there's an audience the tech is
right there you don't need some new
things to happen they're much more
likely to fund you then if you need to
wait for the cost of some technology to
come down if you go out and acquire it
so if we look at driverless cars as an
example the tech isn't there yet but
it's not quite ready for you yet so if
you're planning the big mission around
it you need to wait a little bit right
you can lay the groundwork you can get
it all started but for you to really hit
at home if you need people to have this
as an adopted technology we're not there
yet and so having that as part of your
plan looking at the estimations look at
the growth curve to understand how far
away that is you want to plan that in if
the tech is already ready you don't need
any cost to come down to make that
happen then again you want to write that
into your plan and prepare for it for
yourself and for anybody else who's
looking at the business plan
[Music]
number six is to look at do you need any
other kind of approvals to happen before
you can launch this business or for you
to be able to grow and expand your
business so an example is looking at
loss if you want to start a cannabis
business for example you might need to
wait for some of the government's to
pass laws that are happening it's a big
deal happening here in Canada right now
the federal government here said they're
gonna loosen the laws on cannabis and
allow people to start businesses around
it but it's not ready yet they haven't
said yes yet and so you can start laying
the groundwork but you can't launch
fully until you've got the go-ahead from
the federal government or are you
waiting for some contracts to expire you
know you have this big potential deal
with a customer but they've already
locked in for a couple years with
somebody else you need to wait for that
deal to expire before you can come in or
lease coming in a big way you have a
small chunk you want to take over the
whole piece that can't happen until you
know the contracts have expired you look
at professional sports teams as an
example right you might have a player on
your team you know locked in for three
years you gotta figure out what's gonna
happen after about three years so you
really want to target a player on
another team but they are in a contract
for two years so you gotta wait for
those two years to to wrap up before you
can bring them on board and so do you
need approval for anything are you ready
to go right now or do you need to wait
for some kind of approval from contracts
from the government from somewhere else
for you to be able to do what it is that
you want to do
[Music]
and number seven is do the first small
step what often happens to a lot of
entrepreneurs and this happened to me
too when I first started my first
business is we get so stuck in the
planning of how we think things are
gonna work out and invariably it doesn't
work out like we think it's gonna work
out like no matter how good a plan you
make it's going to change if you look at
the most successful businesses you look
at how they started what their first
business plan idea was it always changed
to what actually made them a success and
so it doesn't mean don't plan because
the plan is good just you have to adapt
the plan what you think of is not what's
actually gonna be birth you'll have to
create it and then adjust and adjust and
adjust and what happens too often is we
get stuck in planning mode because it's
fun and exciting to think about this big
new future that we can build and all the
customers were gonna help and that new
world that we're gonna create it's
really exciting the endorphins are going
off but then we don't do anything right
or we're waiting like well to do that I
need to get investors or I need to get
fun you know I need to get you know all
those all the reasons why you can't go
off and be successful and then you don't
do anything too often and so what I
encourage entrepreneurs to do is have
the big dream how'd the big plan have
the long-term vision for where you want
to go and start small
whatever that first step is doing now
today right so if my goal is to help a
billion entrepreneurs and I'm gonna do
that through create a YouTube channel
don't wait until you have funding to
have a camera guy and an editor and a
researcher and all this other stuff to
happen take out your phone and just make
your first video do that and do another
one to the next day and another one the
next day and so whatever your big plan
looks like break it down into the
tiniest smallest steps of what you can
do immediately today to take one little
itsy-bitsy tiny step forward and then
start doing that instead of waiting for
some magical thing to happen
so that's my advice on the seven ways to
plan for the long term I made this
beauty because Mohit abu-salha
asked me to if there's a topic you'd
like me to cover on a feature seven ways
video check out the link in description
go and cast your vote and I might make a
video just for you I also love to know
what do you think of this video what was
the point that really stood out the most
that you're gonna apply somehow in your
life or in your business leave it down
in the comments below did I miss an 8 9
10 that you want to add to the list
share it in the comments below I look
forward to hearing what you have to say
I also want to give a quick shout out to
best you pro thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
one word and posting it to Twitter I
really really really appreciate the
support and I'm so glad that you enjoyed
the read so thank you again for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is
much love I'll see you see ya the most
important word ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple that would be
kind of like a little beacon hey believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details